it's like we're trapped in some like sex
dungeon and we're just opening up
different doors
chatroulette is a website where you go
and you have video conferences with
total strangers I was always interested
in going on chatroulette bowels a little
too nervous there's gonna be a lot of
nudity I feel bring it on
I think chatroulette is just people
looking for friends it's already hard
enough to be a woman and like you
randomly like get an unsolicited dick
pic I don't need to just like randomly
be honest site like what see what's
gonna happen I expect some day my mother
is probably gonna watch this and like
what if we see your mom on chatroulette
this looks like the 90s like this looks
like AOL aim it's so rude adventure it's
so antiquated rule number one
broadcasting we're offering nudity is
not allowed
oh it's someone in Argentina oh he knows
he passes okay he's cute hey no one oh
wait do they just like keep on yeah
they're hitting next oh that's [ __ ]
we're just dancing with a guy in Russia
right now yeah
shirtless dude another shirtless dude
alright he's typing are you lesbian no
we're not
it's a picture of George Washington okay
he was actually really fun hi help me
come please I'd suck dick for boobs what
oh this is my Batman Joker points Oh
girls I'm serious oh he's wearing a
Gangnam style t-shirt
Oh oh my god he's backing though we saw
flaccid penis it was about yay long just
chilling on his side I like your beard
are you being flirty I'm just you know
have you ever heard of BuzzFeed is my
favorite channel on YouTube is
everything no I don't wanna have phone
sex with me what am i 12
oh she's
oh okay okay
really sweet innocent looking girl she
was very close to the camera and then
she moved back and a guy had an erect
penis and she started sucking it right
in front of it your teacher what do you
teach science oh nice oh please don't
show us your dick
what brings you to chatroulette practice
my English I think oh nice it's very
good
my dream is to be someone done your shot
scared being will say my name and a lot
of people for something to do
can you know who I am that's great you
know right yeah we know the try guys
my favorite the try guys our favorite
hey we met someone who wants to change
the world yes what a wonderful ending we
got to actually make a friend in Spain
we didn't find anyone that was nice and
it just went like it just felt empty and
isolate yeah yeah long it's not it's a
very dark place of the internet it felt
like fishing
you know like once you caught one I
didn't want to offend him I don't want
to scare him off I wanted to have a
conversation I in kind of you know games
trust and faith in chatroulette what
could be very deep is very shallow yes
there is that 1% chance you're gonna
find someone awesome like we found David
but then there's a 99% chance that
you're just gonna be completely scarred
for the rest of your life just dicks
everywhere I'd like just dicks
assaulting the base just dicks in your
dreams this dick nightmare dick surprise
it's here it's here
what get it there [ __ ] I gotta get it
get it you get it it's here quick